how effective do you think cancellation
is at silencing people I saw that sneako
just got another strike on his YouTube
channel Lost His Tick Tock account lost
his Twitter and he seems to not really
see it as a concern Andrew Tate says
that he's got even bigger since he left
and then Steve will do it was at the
NASDAQ announcement thing for rumble as
well do you think that it's cope to say
you get bigger when you're canceled or
is it legit uh it's huge cope
um I think canceling is really good at
getting rid of people it's not very good
at getting rid of ideas though so you
can get rid of the man but you're
probably not going to get rid of the
underlying current of thought that
elevated them to the position they were
in before and that's going to still be
there waiting for another person to kind
of like take the reins on it so they set
a type of rhetoric that
um creates an echo that other people can
then fall into kind of yeah or like
um have you ever heard of a concept
called the Overton window yes
um a lot of people don't know this so
they don't seem to understand this the
Overton window is discovered it's not
created politicians are trying to find
where people are and they can move them
a little bit but it's not like
politicians say this is the Overton
window this is how far right and left
they are it's really a big struggle for
politicians trying to figure out like
where are people and then where can I
kind of like slot in myself so that I'm
popular there so like for instance
Donald Trump didn't necessarily
significantly move the Overton window in
in some direction what three dimensions
or two Dimensions or whatever but uh
more he identified whether
coincidentally or not that's a whole
other conversation but he identify
there's a whole group of Voters that
felt a certain way about something and
he was able to tap into that and when
you've got people like Andrew Tate or
sneako that are getting really big it's
because there's a hunger for that type
of thought it's not like these guys are
creating like nobody had known about
this until take a matter it's that there
are certain people that are hungry for
that type of thought so if you ban him
um the Banning is bad for that person
people will cope and say like oh you
can't get canceled like they got even
bigger well then why didn't they just
delete all their socials before like
there's a reason why people want to be
on these platforms but there's still
going to be that underlying current of
thought and somebody's going to come by
that's another red pillar or mgtow or
whatever and take the reins on it I
think yeah I think you're right I think
based on what I've seen when you remove
people from that ecosystem the audience
at best the absolute best that you can
hope for is it stays as big as it is now
but the discovery medium is these
platforms that have millions and
billions of users right if you're off
YouTube there is no more discoverability
for you if you're off Instagram and Tick
Tock how are people going to find you
you saw this with Alex Jones right Alex
Jones had an a country-sized audience he
got removed from social media but you
know that unless he creates some
incredibly smart referral scheme how are
new people going to discover his message
I mean yeah you're exactly right like
it's yeah I it's such an annoying to
argue with people because it's such a
massive cup otherwise and it betrays
everything we know about like how these
platforms work like if I'm a platform
and I'm buying Talent the reason why I'm
buying talent to come to my platforms
because I'm trying to bring their fan
base over you know I want to be on a
platform where people are there not
because Destiny's there but because
they're watching other people if people
are coming to a platform only for me
that means that that platform doesn't
have anything else left like for me to
to grow from you know like so Rumble is
definitely growing a ton off of Andrew
Tate but I don't think Andrew Tate is
going to grow a ton off of Rumble yes
very interesting well there has to be a
critical mass where Rumble could acquire
so much talent that it might actually
start to move the needle for instance
spotify's acquisition of Cole hadadi and
Rogan
changed what people listened on maybe
there's an argument to be made that
people are going to watch some video
content and there may be a little bit
more platform agnostic but I would argue
that the reason Spotify worked is most
people already had it Spotify was coming
in with a huge amount of existing brand
equity and it's actually a genuinely
better experience for listening to
podcasts on too so it's a superior
product that already had Equity coming
in as opposed to rumble who are kind of
holding on to the coattails of these big
creators that they're bringing over
staple do and sneako tape yeah the books
are still probably being written on how
to do this effectively like nobody
really knows 100 like how do I grow an
alternative platform
um there's a reason why I don't know the
stuff to my head but I'm willing to bet
that like Twitter Facebook these
planners are probably like 15 years old
at this point right
um I know Facebook is at least that old
Twitter is probably I feel like I've
seen tweets from 2008
um so like these are old platforms and
people have tried to start new platforms
buy a bunch of talent and it still kind
of falls through so yeah it's very
difficult to grow a new platform
completely organically unless you're
literally offering like the whole
package like you said it's got to be a
product that's good on its own that is
like why would I use this over something
else it's got to have unique talent
there that you can't find in other
places it's got to have some kind of
discoverability or hook in areas on
other parts of the internet that people
are using like there's a lot that has to
go right and man the barrier to entry
for stuff I got is probably getting
higher and higher and higher every day
like pharmaceutical levels in terms of
how much money you have to spend to get
people over on these platforms yeah yeah
well I mean Tick Tock perfect example
right I thought I thought we'd reached
saturation for the number of different
channels that people would have because
this other stuff I know you hear about
people that use
gab or yikiak you remember Yik Yak do
you ever see that I don't think I did no
so it was location based announcement
kind of like Twitter but it was all
Anonymous so you couldn't see who did it
and it was all location based so you
could basically spread rumors about
people that it was a Gossip Girl but on
a thread and it was completely location
based so you would only see the stuff
that was around you oh I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna remember this but um yeah I
know what you're talking about kind of
there was another app called like
whisper or something it wasn't called
that but it was similar like basically
when you'd open the app there's like 20
things but it's all said by people
locally in Aaron you don't know who it
is right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah my
point being that when I saw those I was
like oh yeah well this will be a cool
thing for maybe a subculture or maybe
it'll try to get off the ground but
probably fail Tick Tock actually managed
to get into the market and hold on to it
because it had a superior product to
everything else that was online without
that and I'm not convinced that Rumble
quite has that yet yeah yeah and I mean
there's going to be companies that um
I'm sure people are going to be doing
case studies on like how they mess
something up because like um
we're on Skype right now right yes what
a letdown that somehow Zoom was able to
come out of nowhere and become like a
massive company like whoever was the
product manager at Skype dropped the
ball on that harder than almost any
other company in history or what if you
were the person that ran Vine and you're
like okay well obviously short form
content like this doesn't work on the
internet mobile app so it's time to
leave and now like 10 years later you've
got like Tick Tock and it's like oh my
God like is that like this is like a guy
the proverbial like 10 000 Bitcoin
holder on an old hard drive somewhere I
was like what mine was he like messed it
up somehow it's like yeah so you know
I'm sure that like I I bet the ultimate
answer if I was God and I could come
down and figure out everything I bet
that there's like 40 is like all of this
like you've got to have the right Talent
the right allocation of resources the
right product blah blah blah and I'm
willing to bet like 50 60 can just be
like right place right time like a lot
of it might just be down to luck like a
certain deal getting signed a certain
thing going viral on the internet that
slowly starts to propagate more uses to
your platform Etc like there's there's
so many variables when it comes to
internet stuff I think you're and yeah
it'll be interesting man it'll be
interesting to see because that like I
said there has to be a um critical mass
let's say that every YouTuber with over
300K Subs move to rumble exclusively
people would people would start watching
that now yes absolutely YouTube would uh
other creators would come through and
fill up some of that watch time
but the question about how much do you
need in order to tip the balance we've
seen this with uh some of the guys that
have moved from twitch to YouTube gaming
that's a big sort of competition that's
going on at the moment and twitch keeps
on seeming to shoot itself in the foot
in the face and the knee and yeah
everything else at the moment
yeah um I agree the um
uh don't I mean take everything I say
they're going to solve it but the one
business model that I want to see try
that hasn't been done yet is I feel like
people are really Keen to buy talent and
then they just do that but they don't
engage with the talent well like I feel
like if I ran another platform I would
want to buy a talent that still
Associates with a lot of people on the
other platform one that's important and
the second thing is I would want to do
something with them that's unique that
they didn't do before so that people
would be like motivated to go and watch
right uh like if somebody was gonna buy
me a talent for a platform you could
stick me somewhere else on me stream but
like are people going to watch it like
I'm still gonna put up YouTube videos
like are they willing to care that much
but if you were to buy me his talent and
then put me on your platform and you did
like a like a boxing series I don't
think I would ever do this but if you
did something crazy like that well now
it's like okay cool yeah he's on a new
platform which is kind of annoying but
he's doing a new cool thing I've ever
seen Live Events with a panel yeah an
audience or some [ __ ] yeah it's not
enough in this day and age
um I don't actually know your background
if you're working like the tech world or
whatnot but like if you're in the
entrepreneurial Tech world there's an
ungodly amount of money that flies
around in these rooms like the worst
projects ever get like seven figure
rounds of funding eight figure rounds of
funding so he's like what is happening
here it's not enough just throw money at
something because if that was the
solution like people would have already
discovered these other platforms you
have to engage with it in a more
intelligent way in a more creative way
than just like oh I paid him you know
five million dollars a year why didn't
he you know grow my platform it's like
you know what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]
thank you